My brother told me that there's a shortcut
through the woods.
I don't know.
C'mon, don't be scared.
I'm not scared!
Then let's go!
It could be dangerous over there. There could be coyotes.
If my brother's done it, it must be safe.
Well... I guess you're right.
I say we try it.
Have you been in there before?
I haven't but my brother has.
What if we get lost?
I can ask my brother the way through and we can go next week.
Deal.
Shake on it?
What's wrong?
These kids...
Let's go!
Think this forest is safe?
It... it will be... fine. Let's just hurry.
Crap, how are we supposed to get across?
I think I see a way across.
You lead the way.
Both: Whoa!
Are you thinking what I'm thinking?
New hangout spot?
This is going to be awesome.
Which way do you think our neighborhood is?
Hmm... let's see.
Spare coins?
Yeah, I think I have some left over from lunch.
Thank you very much. Have a great day.
See? There's nothing scary in this forest.
There you are. Did you bring the requested dosage?
Yeah, I got it.
Wait, don't.
What?
We aren't alone here.
We need a rendezvous point. Somewhere we can safely make the exchange. Most of my usual spots have been compromised, like this one.
Any ideas?
Let's see. Maybe the bridge?
No. Exposed.
Maybe the old factory?
We tried it, they've got a watch on that place.
Can't we just do it at someone's house?
Like your house?
Well... usually my parents are home and--
exactly.
Well, what about the forest?
Oh yeah! We used to hang out there all the
time as kids! No one goes in there. It's perfect.
I hadn't thought of a forest. Which one did
you have in mind?
The one on the side of Puertia Lane. By the
curve, you know?
Yeah, I'm familiar with the neighborhood.
Be there at 5pm tonight. Sharp.
OK, but if you ever want to do business again,
leave my brother's shop alone. No more vandalism.
Just stay away from there from now on.
And you won't find this stuff anywhere else
in town.
Just have it in full, and on time.
Just follow the path until you get to the
meadow.
I'll be waiting. Don't bring anyone.
Haven't been here for a while.
Yeah, can you remember we used to chill here
every day?
Those were the good days.
Before I got tied up in all the drug dealing
shit behind my brother's shop. Man, I miss
being a kid.
Looks like you two were on time. Do you have
the requested dosage?
Yeah. Right here.
Let's take a look.
What is this?
What?
I made it clear to how much I wanted, and
what the hell is this?
Whoa, whoa. Whoa. Whoa.
Where is the rest of it?
Hey, we can get you some more.
I need it now, don't you get it? You guys
are DEAD!
After them!
Hey!
There he is!
Ah! My eyes! Can't see!
Gimme the gun.
Take it.
I'm right here! Ahh.
Let's get you out of here.
I think there really was something scary in these woods Zeke.
It was us.
C'mon stay with me.